what is going on everybody welcome to
tutorial covering the QT designer so up
into this point we haven't really
covered much in the way of layouts
because we've been manually coding
everything fly up iqt in idle so we
haven't really covered layouts because
probably the best way to do layouts is
going to be via QT designer so it's not
so much programming here as far as when
the lay as far as the layout is
concerned but this is going to save you
tons of time so it's pretty stupid not
to use it if you ask me so if you have
pi QT installed and you did the full
installation like I was showing you guys
you should have the QT designer now when
you first open up the QT designer you'll
have this choice here generally you're
going to choose main window or widget
main window is like a main window it
comes with the main menu and stuff so
that's kind of what we want most likely
but yeah so we'll just choose that one
and then what you're what you're given
once it pops up is just a simple window
to work with here and just to talk real
briefly about how the QT designer is
actually laid out itself on the left
hand side here you've got all the
widgets right so you've got some layout
widgets which we haven't talked about
yet but then a bunch of other stuff like
spacers and push buttons and checkboxes
and calendar stuff and labels here just
basically everything right that that is
a part of QT so these are all of our
options and it's really as simple as
click and drag BAM you've got a button
BAM you've got a checkbox want a
horizontal spacer you got it doesn t no
nice all the cart menus here and I don't
know let's add a label too while we're
at it okay so you've got all this kind
of stuff and so what it's allowing us to
do is really just do the layout aspect
so the functionality and the code of you
know what happens when I push a button
we still have to handle that but the
layout we do with QT designer and this
is really really great because
especially when we talk about layouts
here in a moment you'll see that if you
want to deal with those it's going
take a lot so much longer to do it
manually especially if you change your
mind so once you have like a window kind
of set up what you can do is obviously
you can kind of I mean this is basically
the window but if you really want to see
the window right like your horizontal
spacer isn't going to look like that so
what you can do is you can come to form
and then preview either preview which is
control R or you can preview in and you
can preview like the basic styles that
you have access to so you can preview
like these specific things like this or
you can just control R and preview it
you know like this so we have this
window and if we resize this window
though we'll see kind of the same
problem that we had had initially is
that the the window the stuff within the
window doesn't resize as it ought to so
that's what we use layouts for so you
can apply a layout to the entire window
itself by just right-clicking somewhere
in open space and then coming down to
layout and just choose a layout so you
got let's do let's do a horizontal
layout so then I'll just give us like
columns so this would be column 1 column
2 3 & 4
so let's this divider is basically
worthless so I'm going to delete it at
least I thought I was going to delete it
get over here
I can't I can't seem that there oh my
goodness there we go
okay Billy did it okay so we've got
those and then another example here is a
actually let's go to layout let's break
that initial layout and let's give this
a grid layout actually there we go
layout and grid okay so then we can like
move things all around and it kind of
shows us the valid places that we could
stuff stuff now the other nice thing is
you can have the entire window as a grid
layout but then you can throw in another
layout like okay we want one of the grid
spots to be a vertical layout right and
then we can kind of well this one isn't
going to let us change the size but then
we can okay throw in let's throw in a
push button in there then let's try to
stuff something else in there see if we
get away with it yeah so as you can see
this is part of that grid layout that we
just built but then within that grid
lair layout we have a vertical layout as
well so now though let's do control R
and we can see here now we can resize
this and everything resizes with it
right and so that's pretty nice so some
of the other things that we might have a
problem with is like for example this
says text label and this is push button
and check box and all this stuff well to
change that it's pretty simple you just
double click on it and you can put
whatever you want
so we'll put hello there and then push
me and then or me and then but not me
okay and something like that and check
here that's good enough so then on this
that's kind of like this the stuff that
we have on the left-hand side here but
looking on the right-hand side
we have object inspector we've got a
property editor which I didn't mean to
move and then we have resource browser
now I don't really use resource browser
not really sure what its purpose is but
object inspector and property editor are
pretty useful so the object inspector
this is like for your entire window you
know what's going on here you've got the
main window then you've got the central
widget which is this grid layout you've
got the stuff that is within the grid
layout and they've got this new vertical
layout and the stuff that's contained
within it so it's kind of the structure
of the application then down here you've
got the property editor depending on
what you select will show up in this
property editor so we could click on
this button and we get oh it's this push
button and mainly these are just kind of
the settings you probably won't change
these very very often but one thing you
should definitely always change is the
object name so the object name here's
push-button this is the object name like
in your code so this button is defined
by push button this one push button
three this one push button - that's not
very useful so before we push this to
Python code we definitely want to rename
these so maybe this one would be um you
know but not me right to be kind of
going along with the name of the button
itself and then we could name this one
you know push me and then this one could
be or me
I whoops highlight it a little too much
there or me okay so you can do stuff
like that also if you ever wanted to
change like the windows title you can't
like you can't really click on the
window and it pop-up but you can come
over to the object inspector click on
main window and then you come down here
to window title and you can change the
window title so I don't know QT type
that's what I'll call it so there's that
also if you want to add like a menu you
can totally do that just double click
there start typing stuff right file open
save let's add a separator BAM and then
exit okay
instantly done all right that would have
taken it's like you know I don't know
three or four minutes to do we just did
it like instantly and then here luckily
for us we've got action open this one
says action save this one's action at
exit so this one actually makes a little
more sense automatically you don't have
to change the name but you can if you
want so there's that and then obviously
if you wanted to add more items as you
kind of do stuff here right if I added
edit here it gives us a new option later
you know so as you add more to this menu
bar it just automatically adds stuff you
know so if you wanted to you could now
now how do we actually get this to
Python code so if you're on Windows and
you go say form view code you might get
this error this is like unknown error it
makes no sense to me why this error
still is in existence but it is so what
we want to do if that didn't work for
you is you can go file save as and we
can save this I'm going to save it in
this really deep directory in testing
and we're going to call this a PI QT
designer and it'll be a dot UI file
that's just what it's being saved as
we'll go ahead and save that no problem
so I have that file now it's just right
in here and what we want to do now is
open up a console in there so open
command window into there so make sure
you're in the the actual directory of
that file right so that's where the file
is that's the path
to this file so if you don't know how to
do that you can always aq hold shift and
right click the directory and you can
open a command window there so once
you've done that now we have to enter in
some code to get this to convert so if
you if you can you could sometimes get
away with just doing PI UIC - X for
executable and then we can change we can
say PI QT designer UI that's what it's
say this yeah and then - oh for the
output file and we're just we'll say PI
QT designer PI but I don't think this
will end up working for me but it might
work for you we'll try it right so it's
probably gonna come up and say it's not
recognized as a command so now we need
to reference that pi q t UI or PI UIC
file it's like a batch file so now let's
reference that so it would be C colon
slash Python 34 or whatever version
you're using and then Lib slash site -
packages / pi QT 4 or 5 or 6 or whatever
is at the time that you're watching this
/pi UI c 4 or 5 and whatever dot bat and
then same thing as before x4 executable
if you don't use the X it just won't be
X it won't like actually create a window
it'll just be a bunch of definitions you
can run it but it's not going to do
anything and then we want to do this pi
QT designer uy and then we want to do
the - oh and then we'll do the output to
PI QT designer PI okay so we'll do that
hit enter and you should now have a new
file there right it should be PI QT
designer we can open it and edit with
Idol here's all that code again there's
no real functionality - it's just the
layout and just the UI only but let's go
ahead and run that and sure enough
here's our window and that's that so
you've got all the Python code there you
did it in the designer obviously this
isn't really any advanced code but hey
we built that in like 10 minutes
so that would have taken us a lot longer
in ten minutes to build all of that
including especially thinking about like
the layouts that are involved here and
then like what happens when you're like
hmm I want to change layouts well that's
a really kind of a challenge especially
if you have like a lot of stuff inside
your layouts to kind of mentally go
through what what objects need to be
moved to what place in your code that's
that's pretty hard and so having the QT
designer there just it makes it so much
simpler so anyways that's just a really
quick introduction to QT designer
obviously there's a whole lot more to it
this was kind of a silly application but
from here all we really need to do is
you know use connect to connect
functions to these buttons but we've
already covered how to do that so I'm
not going to waste any time and do these
simple connections to the buttons but
hopefully you can see now how powerful
just QT designer is because really as
far as I know there's no TK designer but
maybe I'm wrong if I'm wrong let me know
but QT designer just makes things so
much easier so anyways that's it for
this tutorial if you have any questions
or comments go ahead and leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions
until next time